well today is uh just a wonderful day
first of all and it's so good that i
even i dressed i'm not dressed like a
slob for the first time on the air
that's how that's how important today is
um it's been nearly
50 years since roe v wade was decided
for half a century
we've lived under its tyranny those of
us who were lucky enough to live at all
that is actually uh you know because 60
million of us did not live over 60
million human children have been wiped
off the face of the earth during that
time executed one by one systematically
for profit all because nine guys in
robes pulled out their decoder rings
from their cracker jack boxes and found
the right to abortion written in
invisible ink somewhere in the document
and that was enough justification to
legalize the destruction of innocent
human life all across the country for
almost half a century
it's impossible to know what our society
deprived itself of what it sacrificed
aside from its soul
could one of the babies we killed have
come up with a cure for cancer could
there have been great leaders and
artists and thinkers and humanitarians
somewhere in that pile of bodies
almost certainly there were
how many inventors and pioneers were
thrown into the mass grave before they
even had a chance to speak to plead for
themselves to tell their side of the
story
we'll never know for sure because roe
robbed us of that just as it robbed 60
million children of their lives and of
their potential
until today
as expected for the last month and
prayed for and fought for and worked
towards for the last five decades by
pro-lifers roe was officially overturned
by the supreme court decision today uh a
decision originally leaked a few weeks
ago in a desperate bid to intimidate at
least one of the justices into changing
their minds the gambit did not pay off
indeed it probably backfired as roberts
joined chief justice robert to join the
majority decision over turning rose
something he almost certainly was not
planning to do until the decision leaked
and so it stands it stands even stronger
arguably than it did in its leaked form
and the result is that roe is no more
praise god
this is truly i mean truly one of the
greatest days in american history future
generations will look back on this day
you are living in a day right now you
are experiencing a day
that will be in the history books that
future generations will look back on and
they will look back on it the way that
they that we now look back on the
abolition of slavery or the defeat of
the germans in world war ii the
liberation of the concentration camps
they will look back on it the exact same
way
because there's a lot of gray area in
life there's many occasions where the
good guys aren't very distinguishable
from the bad guys but this
this belongs to the other category of
events this is the category where the
line between good and evil could not be
more clear
one side
has fought to protect babies from
extermination
and they have fought this and fought for
this for the sake of those babies of
those children
you know we pro-lifers we stand to gain
nothing personally from the end of row
we don't profit
off of it in any way at all
there's nothing self-serving about it
we fight for those who cannot fight for
themselves and this is really hard for
the left to understand because they
never do this everything they fight for
it's always for themselves
always
if they cannot directly profit from it
in some kind of way they do not fight
for it and they do not care
which is why they could never understand
us they never understood us as
pro-lifers they're always looking for
what's really going on here what's going
on below the surface what's the
nefarious plan what's that they're
trying to control women's bodies they
have a secret conspiracy it's none of
that
we just don't think you should kill
babies
simple as that
we care about those babies
the other side they fight to destroy
innocent life
and they fight for it for their own sake
for their own convenience for their own
precious lifestyle and comfort
they're the bad guys
history will see them
as the bad guys we'll see them that way
we'll look back on them with scorn
and you should know that also if you're
on the left and today you're very upset
and you're screaming and crying about it
that all of history will look back at
you
and and with scorn and mockery and
derision
as well as should
because you lose you lose big today you
lose historically
and look they're going to explode in
demonic rage they're going to protest
and riot they will destroy probably kill
to satiate their bloodlust but none of
that will change anything and all of it
will be worth it in the end let these
psychopaths burn every city to the
ground i will still thank god
that roe is no more
now i don't think they're actually going
to follow through on a lot of this stuff
i think a lot of it is just a big talk
i think i think that the pro-abortion
militants are hoping hoping and and uh
praying to satan
that that will have you know the blm
riots of 2020 all over again that will
have months and months of chaos and
riding in the street that's what they're
hoping for that's what they're trying to
organize i don't think it's actually
going to happen
because i don't think
that there are enough people and maybe
i'll be proven wrong about this
i don't think there are enough people
who care that much about killing babies
to generate the kind of mass nationwide
chaos that the left is hoping for here
we'll see
now this does not end the scourge of
abortion we should note that
uh may come as a shock to many of the
pro-abortion demons convulsing in the
street and vomiting all over themselves
like linda blair and the exorcist but in
fact abortion will remain legal in many
u.s states including our most populous
states in fact nearly every pro-abortion
militant now promising a night of rage
as revenge
actually lives in a place where their
so-called right to abortion quote
unquote will remain intact
actually i expect that uh the remaining
abortion states will double and triple
down consoling themselves by making
abortion even more accessible even more
legal even more easy to obtain
i'm putting my marker down right here i
don't think this year will come to a
close before at least one state
officially legalizes infanticide
expanding abortion rights into the first
several months of a child's life outside
the womb
that's on the
way and yet even so this decision today
will nonetheless directly save millions
of lives
there is no question about that it is
not every day that something like this
happens that there's an event in history
that happens and we live through it and
because of that event millions of people
will live who otherwise would have died
i mean the the course of history has
been changed in ways that
uh we cannot possibly
tabulate or quantify we never will be
able to
it's important also to note something
else
that this decision made by the court
is not just morally right though it is
of course morally right manifestly and
self-evidently so it's also the right
legal decision because even if somehow
you have no moral qualms with a
dismemberment of children
you must if you're honest and understand
the way the law is supposed to work
you must agree that roe was bad law bad
precedent a bad decision built on a
foundation so flimsy that to call it
merely flimsy probably does it a favor
i want to read a little bit from the
decision itself um today
it says quote
without any grounding in that
constitutional text history or precedent
row imposed on the entire country a
detailed set of rules for pregnancy
divided into trimesters much like those
that one might expect to find in a
statute or regulation
roe's failure even to note the
overwhelming consensus of state laws in
effect in 1868 is striking
and what it said about the common law
was simply wrong
then after surveying history the opinion
spent many paragraphs conducting the
sort of
fact-finding that might be undertaken by
a legislative committee and did not
explain why the sources on which it
relies shed light on the meaning of the
constitution
as the precedent citing a broad array of
cases the court found support for a
constitutional right of personal privacy
but roe conflated the right to shield
information from disclosure and the
right to make and implement personal
decisions without governmental
interference
none of these decisions involved what is
distinctive about abortion its effect on
what rho termed potential life when the
court summarized the basis for the
scheme it imposed on the country it
asserted that its rules were consistent
with among other things the relative
weight of the respective interests
involved in the demands of the profound
problems of the present day
these are precisely the sort of
considerations that legislative bodies
often take into account when they draw
lines that accommodate competing
interests the scheme produced looked
like legislation and the court provided
the sort of explanation that might be
expected from a legislative body
okay now
the entire decision is uh very much
worth reading but that passage alone
summarizes i think
a central element of the majority's
decision
basically to translate the decision to
affirm a constitutional right to
abortion quote unquote
was not grounded in the text of the
constitution because it's not in the
text of the constitution
it wasn't even grounded in precedent or
historical tradition it had no grounding
at all aside from the claims and
preferences of the justices who decided
it
what they came up with then was not a
legal decision rigorously argued but a
kind of pseudo legislation that looks
and sounds and functions like something
that a legislative committee might come
up with
and that's reason enough to overturn it
no matter how you feel about abortion
and you can really see the contrast
between row itself that decision and the
decision abolishing it today
the latter the decision abolishing it is
thorough logical
deeply argued
while the former is it what it was now
we say was shallow often absurd full of
subjective assertions and it danced
around and avoided the fundamental
question which of course is what we
always find on the left
they could never take any issue head-on
they can never talk about it directly
everything is covered in euphemism
everything is just a game of beating
around the bush
because here is the most fundamental
question
that all pro-abortion people everywhere
avoid it's the question that the rioters
in the street tonight while they're
looting and burning will have no answer
to and probably haven't even thought
about and that is this
what is a person
we know they can't tell us what a woman
is which won't stop them from claiming
that today represents a grave assault on
women's rights
but that confusion is not surprising
since they long before
gave up on the definition of the word
person
i mean before they gave up on the
definition of word woman the word woman
they'd given up on the definition of the
word person which means that we had
already become these kinds of sort of
vague hazy
ambiguous um undefinable undefined
lumps of of matter you know that's
that's what a person is now it's like
nothing at all
and of course if that's the case then
any other label you put on the person
also doesn't really make any sense
because we don't know we don't know
anything about the underlying person
for 50 years they claimed that the
question is irrelevant
they said well nobody knows what a
person is it's impossible to say so
let's just keep killing these babies
just in case
but any morally sane person realizes
that it should go the other way
if you can't tell me what a person is
then you can't say for certain that the
child in the womb is not one
which means even by your own logic you
should refrain from killing him
if you point a gun at somebody not
knowing if it's loaded or not and you
pull the trigger
you're still legally liable if it turns
out there was a bullet in the chamber
after all unless your name is alec
baldwin of course the same goes for
abortion
by the pro board's own telling
they exterminated 60 million human
children who might have been people for
all they know
that's not any better than exterminating
60 million human children who you know
are people
especially in this case
because in fact everyone knows that
babies are people
even if they pretend to be confused
about it
everyone knows it a person is a human
being
the child in the womb cannot be anything
other than a member of the human species
which he which means he cannot be
anything other than a person
these are people
they have been killing people
millions of them and they know it
and they'll answer to god for what
they've done
but today we celebrate their defeat
there's a lot of work yet to be done you
know the battle is uh just beginning in
many ways
but it's i think it's very important to
celebrate the victories when they come
and this is a victory
i mean this is a major one
this is one of the greatest victories
for human rights in the history of the
world i think i would even say
perhaps
the greatest victory for human rights in
the history of the world
and it's one that i thought i would
never live to see
[Music]
in summation
what a great way to end pride month
i know you're uh craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there